just to break the mating net around the  white king but if we catch up with the  current position the reason this is  winning now for black is because there  are too many threats there's a threat  against the bishop which needs to stay  defending this loose rook but also some  checkmating ideas at some point  the problem is wherever you move the  bishop if you move it forward for  example the rook will come back hitting  the bishop and also a double threat of  mating the king  this one looks over now the white bishop  will drop  yeah very very impressive play um again  i keep saying it about richard but he  he's done this he's done this  fantastically well  and um this must be the end now because  you're not even going to win that last  black pawn uh there's a checkmate on the  board a threat against the bishop and  do we have a result now we do  it's a win for  richard uh report and a very nice win as  well they lost another one forehands  niemann is in a bad period hans nima